like its warmth I love it and then years
later this is what happened I checked my
Facebook and she said that she was a
dominatrix yeah you at little I remember
you how long did you work is it yeah um
so I was a dominatrix for a year
mm-hmm that was when I was 19 and this
guy just like randomly walked up to me
on the street and he was like hey do you
want to be in the sex or the adult
entertainment industry and I was like
yeah I do and then I went upstairs to
his dungeon know and I started training
but why I don't like why was there any
other thing you could have been yeah um
at the time like I didn't even know what
my options were like I didn't know a
stripper or even a hooker or anything
like that like I you know like I went to
a private school and I like it's I don't
know like I just didn't know anyone like
that and so this guy came up to me and I
was like oh my god this is my chance and
it just happened to be that he ran he
was the manager at a dungeon and at that
point I was like what a pimp I probably
would have been like yes I got it for
$20 so when you were 17 I could have
gone hey I give you like $1,000 are you
kidding it could have been fifty dollars
I read it wrong wrong
so in terms of training what do you do
like what is training about masses
basically so the guy that I'm the guy
that ran it he was the manager and he
was the manager of the night shift so
that's like the position I was put in so
I think I started work at midnight and
went till like 7:00 a.m. or something
and he he himself was like a submissive
guy and so basically I trained on him
which I mean looking back is totally
creepy but like I I you know I did crazy
[ __ ] to him like I put a catheter in his
dick yeah like I would [ __ ] his pee hole
with this like electrocuting thing I've
learned since then I like that you're
touching your dick
I'm asking meeting I was protecting in
[Music]